المجموعة في الواقع هي لأنها
حكايات بوش والإلهام من
الزي الوطني الموحد للرجال ، كان لديهم
قطعة واحدة تسمى ستار بوش
منذ وقت طويل عندما كان قدامى المحاربين يعيشون
في خيمة ، كان لكل عائلة
عطرها الخاص ومن ثم من
العائلة التي كانوا يمرون بها ،
يمكنك معرفة العائلة التي كانوا
ينتمون إليها فقط من خلال رائحتهم ،
وعندما اعتاد المحاربون القدامى السفر مجانًا لمدة
ستة أشهر ، غطت الجدة
التركية في العطر
وربطت بـ akan Dora ، لذلك عندما سافروا كانوا
دائمًا ما تتمتع برائحة منزل
أحبائهم الذين أرادوا ابتكار
منتج جميل جدًا أصيل
وعصري ومعاصر ، لذلك من
الأصل الذي يؤثر على tear bush ،
أنشأنا سوارًا يمكنك وضع العطر
واستخدامه من أجلك وأيضًا
في الواقع ، ناشر العطور لدينا ومن ثم
لدي شجيرات جولة عملاقة في النادي
والتي تدخل في الواقع في أسلوب
الحياة البدوية من الخيمة المصنوعة
من القش الذهبي  r ثم الانتقال إلى
نسج أوراق النخيل المجففة ، ثم
آخرها هو في الواقع تقنية
للرسالة وراء هذا المشروع بالنسبة
لي كان مهمًا جدًا لحماية الحرف
اليدوية والمساعدة في العيش لفترة أطول لأن هذا هو
الجيل الأخير من السيدات اللائي
يعرفن  الحرف اليدوية بشكل جيد وأردت حقًا
أن أتعلم وأردت أن أشاركها
مع الجميع مع جيل الشباب
[موسيقى]